hello well back then I'm sorry I know
then what's that bong in the backseat Oh
donk that's funny that's a sculpture
that I I made in school I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're thinking driving
around with a bong in the backseat of
your car who do you think you are Willy
Nelson
maybe he got arrested really time is a
terrible way of eating by my mom wrote
that to me in a letter when I was eight
okay I got a dump out she will leave you
like [ __ ] at school I'm only having
two weeks left with you guys what a dick
it what are we gonna do next year we're
doing like cool brooding winter drugs
like opium together near each other okay
my little cruise director okay would you
rather have penises the fingers or
vaginas for years dick fingers you
cannot wear rings but if you have
vaginal ears you could wear earrings
[Laughter]
you know moment when you just know
you're not gonna be a professional
athlete I kind of had one tonight
well that moment that you had comes a
little later for black vote yes I gets
you though I do NYU and I'm going to
Columbia we're gonna be like partners
forever I don't even know if that's 100%
why I want to do what where the [ __ ] is
Lily I know I know I should close here
to list our token white friends donkey
bone they're with us through high school
life death SATs
prom recently us like when you know
things are ending you freak out you try
to hold on I think you get so wise man
it's friendly but brilliant women aren't
supposed to be in my class right now
aren't you supposed to be in your class
right now this never happened
[Music]
you